People get super passionate and downright
angry about politics - to the point that researchers
believe it might be making us less racist.
How does that work?
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews.
I love debating, but realizing that it can
lead to fierce arguments, my wiser than I
best friend always advised me to keep my mouth
shut at family dinners when it came to politics.
But what is it about political disagreements
that gets us so riled up?
Well, it has a lot to do with what anger IS
at its core.
Biologically, your heart rate, blood pressure,
and testosterone increase.
Your body also releases norepinephrine which
numbs our physical and emotional pain, and
epinephrine - also known as adrenaline - which
acts like an amphetamine making you feel in
control.
Your cortisol levels or stress hormones decrease;
What’s more, you become irrational.
Because while anger can activate the left
prefrontal cortex which increases logical
thinking and reasoning, it only does so if
there seems to be a solution to the situation.
This perhaps explains why people keep at it
for hours - arguing and debating with no end
in sight.
So if rationality goes out of the window,
what’s the evolutionary advantage of getting
angry?
Well, Darwin once observed that expressing
anger affects “animals of all kinds, and
their progenitors before them, when attacked
or threatened by an enemy, to fight and protect
themselves.”
Anger’s evolutionary advantage then, seems
to be connected to a protection mechanism
that shields us and our clan from the threats
of outsiders.
And as part of this protection system and
its development, it would have been incredibly
evolutionary advantageous to accurately determine
who is and who isn’t part of our group.
Obviously, grouping ourselves in terms of
who has smaller or longer pinky toes isn’t
very useful…what is important when picking
someone to be a part of our group is whether
that person might cooperate or compete with
us.
Researchers at The University of California
Santa Barbara, the London School of Economics
and Aarhus University teamed up to discover
if political ideology is one of the categories
we use to determine if someone is “one of
us.”
They were particularly interested if the alliance
detection system, as they call it, would be
activated in participants minds when the political
views of others were presented.
Each study volunteer was shown a video of
a conversation between eight people, what
they didn’t know was that four of them were
republicans and four were democrats - also
half of the republicans were white and half
were black - same for democrats.
Once the video was complete, the participants
were then given snippets of the transcript
from the discussion and asked to categorize
the individuals.
What the researchers found, was that the study
volunteers predominantly categorized individuals
in the video by political beliefs and not
by race.
Through other variations of this experiment
they discovered that while that while things
like age and sex are social categories that
help us organize the world, political leanings
and race are part of our alliance categories
that help us figure where we belong.
And the fact that politics overrides race
when it comes to choosing our alliances, means
there is something special about our political
views that can bond us together or break us
apart.
This is probably why we get so angry when
talking politics.
It’s not really about economic policy, abortion,
or health care - it’s actually about group
affiliation - about identifying members with
whom to cooperate or compete.
And, it might be especially infuriating when
it’s a family member or friend who disagrees
with because you may have considered them
a part of your group in other situations.
When it comes to politics, it’s not debate,
it’s war.
Which is why when you’re talking politics
around the family dinner table, you can end
up feeling betrayed.
Sometimes to the point of fist fighting and
full-on brawls.
Which makes you wonder if humans are naturally
violent.
Lucky for us, Trace did an episode on just
that.
Check
it out.
Do you enjoy watching or participating in
political debates?
I hate to admit it, but the primary debates
have been one of my favorite things to watch
this year.
Share your thoughts in the comments and remember
to subscribe so you never miss an episode
of DNews.
Thanks for watching.